And at first, I want you and me to derive this
mathematically and it is challenging if you don’t
like calculus, you can skip over it. So feel free to
skip. If you skip, no one is ever going to know
and I promise you derivation is not essential for
using this formula over here. You can use
entirely without understanding why it’s correct.
But if you stick with me, you get a sense of how
statistics really works as a scientific discipline.
So it’s a glimpse into the beauty of more
advanced statistics. So last chance, you’re going
to skip? Hey, thanks for staying on.
So here’s my quiz and it looks complicated but
let me explain it to you. I better derive for you
the desired equation on here which is the
maximum likelihood estimator all the way from
the definition of the probability of the data. You
might remember data is comprised of XIs where
each XI is 1 one for heads and zero for tails.
And of course, P is the desired probability of
heads. I left open the derivation, however, nine
steps or where these nine bars that will turn into
boxes very soon, and what you have to do is
you have to pick from the 13 choices over here,
the ones that fit best. There is always a unique
answer and you can only use each of the things
on the right side once. So there will be four
things left, 13 minus 9, that you’ve never used.
So for example, if you believe that the right
answer over here is PN, then you’re going to
type 6 into the box over here and PN is now
used, you can't write 6 anywhere else. So good
luck with this. The way the proof works is by first
taking the logarithm of this expression over here,
this ends up over here and we said the first
derivative is zero. So you have to complete the
first derivative and plug in here and then you
have to transform it all the way until you achieve
the final result. Good luck.